an diesem bahnübergang in haarhausen in
thüringen spielen sich bemerkenswerte
dinge ab jedes mal wenn sich die beiden
halbschranken einwandfrei schließen
sichern zwei mitarbeiter der bahn den
übergang zusätzlich mit rot weißem
flatterband tag für tag rund um die uhr
seit januar rätseln die menschen in
hahausen was das wohl zu bedeuten hat
einfach mal gedacht okay noch zwei drei
wochen sind sie wieder weg und obwohl
mittlerweile sind so sehr lange schon
bald zum dorf und keiner weiß warum
na ja es ist schon ziemlich irritierend
weil ich bin ja nicht der einzige dienst
da sehr verwundert dass ein
funktionierender an den burgern
gesichert wird es ist total überflüssig
desto extra noch ben dahin gemacht
werden weil wenn zu ist es zu wir waren
übergangen liegt auf der strecke
zwischen arnstadt und erfurt bei
routinekontrollen hat die deutsche bahn
festgestellt bei einzelnen zugfahren ist
der übergang länger als vier minuten
geschlossen nun besser zu lang als zu
kurz sollte man meinen nicht so die bahn
denn die fürchtet jetzt ungeduldige
autofahrer könnten versuchen die
halbschranken zu umfahren um die
potenziellen bruchpiloten vor sich
selbst zu schützen muss eine weitere
sicherung her und zwar per hand und so
werden seit januar vor jeder zug durch
fahrt zusätzlich zu den halbschranken
und den roten ampeln auch noch
flatterbänder gespannt die halbschranke
schließt immer pünktlich und dieses
flattert ein zusätzlicher daher schranke
das banner ansicht nach ein aufwendig
der nicht gerechtfertigt essen die
deutsche bahn steht zu ihrem multi
schriftlich heißt es bei der bahn geht
sicherheit immer vor
daher haben wir in abstimmung mit dem
eisenbahn-bundesamt der aufsichtsbehörde
der deutschen bahn beschlossen den
bahnübergang bis zur technischen
überarbeitung zusätzlich durch einen
bahnübergangs posten zu sichern
lange zeit war es kein problem und jetzt
so ein aufwand in hahausen schlagen sie
die hände über dem kopf zusammen wenn
die schranke unten ist eine halbschranke
ebenfalls dann habe ich zu warten bis
die schranke wieder hochgeht und wenn
das zehn minuten dauert definitiv
es gibt wirklich andere bahnübergänge
dies mehr bräuchten ich kann es mir
nicht vorstellen dass jemand drum herum
fährt zum einen und zum anderen ist der
aufwand und nutzen für mich nicht
gegeben wie lange die bahn den
zusätzlichen personellen aufwand noch
umsetzt und wie viel das eigentlich
kostet keine auskunft die jobs am
bahnübergang in haarhausen scheinen
jedenfalls bis auf weiteres sicher